Argentina has voted for a new president
amidst a worsening economic crisis
opposition candidate Alberto Fernandez
has won more than 47 percent of the vote
compared to President Mauricio macri's
41 percent Fernandez campaigned on
mattress failure as president to stem
poverty and inflation in his victory
speech Fernandez thanked his opponent
who conceded defeat with 85 percent of
the votes counted my first words are to
thank the entire Argentinian people who
voted who lived and built a historic day
for democracy that has put order and
logic into Argentina again thanks to
everyone who voted for us all of those
who accompanied us and supported us
thank you for the commitment that you've
demonstrated to truly build a supportive
Argentina and an Argentina of solidarity
one that defends public education one
that defends public health with that
being dad I want to congratulate
president-elect Alberto Fernandez I just
talked to him for the great choice that
people have made I invited him tomorrow
to breakfast because he has to start a
transition period please this is for
Argentina the orderly transition that
brings tranquility to all Argentines
because here the only important thing is
the future and well-being of Argentines
well the center of Buenos Aires is
filled with people celebrating chantings
the return of the pyrenees party to
power it's something that they're saying
that in the end once again this
elections confirmed the fight for social
justice that the fairness party is known
for we just heard elected president
Alvaro Fernandez speaking about unity
speaking to those who did not vote for
him and asking for their help saying
that the times that are coming in
Argentina are gonna be difficult ones
especially because of the economic
situation and this is something very
important because there are many people
in this country who are afraid of the
comeback of the Paradis party of
Kirchner ISM of the party of former
President Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner
who is currently running who's currently
vice president has recently been elected
as vice president in the country so a
lot of Fernandez message has also been a
for him we also heard president Mauricio
Macri talking about a peaceful
transition of inviting Alberto Fernandez
to have breakfast this Monday with him
in order to plan what they expected to
be a peaceful transition when the new
president takes office on December 10th
this have been very very difficult
economic times for Argentina times when
people have been going to the banks
changing their pesos for US dollars
because they do not trust in the banking
system taking their money out the
government is currently struggling with
very high inflation poverty rates the
possibility of a default so if strategic
most analysts and most economies say
that there is a clear plan for the next
month because the next president takes
over in two months and it's necessary to
know what measures the next president is
going to take in order to bring some
stability